I'm Sonic
boy I hope he doesn't Park that in
Roseanne and Tom spot boy
I have to tell you I'm so glad the
entrance is over because I've been under
such pressures you can imagine that
everyone's been talking about how's he
coming out how's he come out I know he's
coming out he's coming out like this
everybody wanted me to come out like
them because I thought it was good luck
two good men said come out like a marine
you know get like Jack and a tight
close-up you can't handle the truth then
people said come out like Clint and then
The Crying Game said you know just come
out so I'm here so here we are actually
the most nervous people in the audience
have got to be the producers of The
Crying Game who are looking at me now
and going don't say a word I'll be good
for a while I will not reveal the secret
of that great movie but I have to say
for me that big scene proved one thing
white men can jump
boy talk about a stocking stuffer I'll
tell you that right now
but this is this is the 65th Academy
Awards I'm delighted to be here I almost
did not show I have to tell you I tried
to pull out last week but I had this
oral agreement and they helped me too
tonight is a night where we honor people
for individual achievement and also for
bodies of work and looking at this crowd
some of your bodies have had a lot of
work I can't believe it
but the theme tonight is women in film
and ironically 1992 has been a very poor
year for women's parts in fact some of
the most talked-about women's parts are
Sharon Stone's and Basic Instinct
it's not been a great year for women in
film I asked him Basinger she'll give
you 9 million reasons why it's not been
a great I wouldn't want to live in the
town - Chee owns I'll tell you that
there's gonna be a tax hike oh one
minute you're a movie star the next to
the Sheriff of Nottingham you know what
I'm saying but it has been a great year
for all kinds of movies this year big
Hollywood extravaganzas like a few good
men the J Edgar Hoover story talked
about a best-kept secret I'm telling it
Hoover was the master of disguise really
for seven years he was on The Andy
Griffith Show as aunt bee gotta admire
him not only did he catch Dillinger he
was the lady in red this is interesting
thing and then there were smaller
personal movies like a river runs
through it lovely film two hours of
fly-fishing
I love the movie I had trouble relating
to it because in my family the closest
we get to fly-fishing is pass the locks
also animated movies Aladdin was an
enormous hit it made almost as much
money as Michael Eisner did Disney now
working on a new animated film the
animated Amy Fisher story beauty and the
middle-aged Beast so and now they bought
a hockey team Disney has bought a hockey
team at Disney hockey team used to be
the only Disney on ice was Walt I mean
what is this man oh come on that's why
we're black for that joke and this is
also the year the independent film the
British Invasion Howards End nine
nominations might made but of course by
the talented Merchant Ivory team will do
with these great period classics such as
room with a view nine nominations and
now I think to their credit they won't
do something more contemporary so
they're gonna make a movie with Spike
Lee yeah it's gonna be called Howard's
Beach
it's good job
we also had a lot of controversy this
year the first time a nomination has
been disallowed the Uruguayan film a
place in the world was disqualified in
the Foreign Language Film category
apparently what happened was the South
American director hired an American
nanny and and use it but the thrill for
me is as your host tonight and for the
pastor you just look at Ana swords and
see all of these great stars this is
what it's all about Clint Eastwood who
are you nine nominations Unforgiven I'm
a big fan you know that plane of course
played that ruthless character and you
know that he used those same tactics
when he cleaned up that lawless renegade
town of Carmel California when he was
the mayor there there was dodge
tombstone and Carmel it was Clint
Eastwood who instituted the know creme
brulee after 10:00 p.m. ordinance
it's true only Clint Eastwood could
stare at local resident and burr under
the saddle Darst a looker right in the
eyes and say curb those dogs but the
best love to see Jack right in the front
row man I love it
all right now look at it I love you like
this huh
it's sort of Armani meets Jiminy Cricket
I love it I mean it I love Jackie
sitting like this smile at me I feel
like a Laker girl it's unbelievable but
Jack the glasses man you're indoors the
dark glasses you're indoors you know why
you need it you're such a big star your
own luster gets in your eyes that's how
big you are man you should have a number
three on the back of your tux you're
Babe Ruth to me I mean
see now once the nominations come out
Jack this is Jack's tenth nomination it
ties him with Sir Laurence Olivier and
they David handbag now
once the nominations are announced the
campaigning goes on people want your
vote people want you to see them will we
see the cassettes these are some of the
things that you get people at home you
get all of these things look at what I
got this is from the producers of Woody
Allen screenplay
husbands and wives they sent this to me
so I thought this was interesting
distance cassette and then we see it
again
sees its thing - did it on 60 minutes
it's ok to do it here
then a league of their own the story of
the women's baseball team was wanted you
to notice Madonna's performance in that
so they sent from the movie her bustier
and cup which I thought was interesting
it was for Best Supporting Actress and
and a personal favorite of mine Al
Pacino nominated for two awards best
actor and Best Supporting layout
I wasn't at all surprised with the two
nominations cuz look when he sent me
this thing here I got this thing here
this is heavy okay
hi and you all know Salman Rushdie you
know
everybody's dressing up
you know every year for the past four
years I've I poke a little fun at the
academy and I've done a funny medley of
opening numbers sort of poking fun at
the traditional what I felt were kind of
strange opening numbers that we've had
to endure over the past few years and
the Academy kind of got upset with me
for making fun of their opening numbers
where I take the nominated songs and put
them into one medley
so tonight unfortunately there will be
no medley tonight no all right
tonight you will not hear me sing the
whole night Roz Roz who will win the
nominees the best picture are
geom tango across the floor
watch him drink and hear him roar he's
shrunk he's blind and yet he drives
- how the hell is he still alive
w holdin me and who won't say it again
tonight - say now you may not lose it is
the Oscar you can't trip you you got the
Perkins felon always yelling nephew
choke and cigar smoking skirt-chasing
booze tapes and family members chick
sniffing blue
and I'm just getting started
hooray for Howard ten I really hope this
picture starts a trend a picture with no
lot of perspiration just conversation no
cycle weights round the bend and not an
ounce of smarts and ankle Howard's but
they call it Howard ran now listen up
every time I say something to you you
will repeat it back to me
are we clear I don't know but I've been
told your big name three movie gold to
me and Tom put you in the Black Hawk
your house and get me Jack I hope you
good man to celebrate the old house it
directly not nominated nominations
don't figure Rob no more
just watch for you Jack you see a pair
of flash and I
your hand starts creeping up her thighs
you're hurried to a spot your heart the
trot board is named
those eyes those thighs surprise its The
Crying Game
one more time though I know spiced rum
ride it's the crying games I didn't
order that
Unforgiven that's what you are
you killed everyone cause you're the
star to make a big mare you you directed
and produce with the long way from
singing I talk to the trees may I be the
last to say tonight may make your day
forgiving
for our $0.10 of a woman the crying
games are a few good men
that's the list of all five nominees now
before I slide down on my knees mr.
Saturday night
I just wanted to see how it would feel
so sue me
may I have oh give me the envelope
I go